did you hang with a lot of Hollywood
people I don't know I
don't know but I don't hang with many
people you know I'm kind of a homebody
so I don't go to like a lot of parties
and get togethers but you know a lot of
my friends are in the biz or in comedy
so uh uh and I still have some of the
same friends that I had in college like
my friend Joel I've known since college
so one of my closest friends but yeah
well the guy you wrote the movie with
and and
isn't that a you guys have been if you
worked together for a long time well I I
met him he bought he bought funny or die
right or no no no no no no no no
he worked for funny he worked for funny
yeah so I I actually met him uh when he
did the first weird the Al Yankovic
story fake video trailer back in 2010.
uh so he approached me and said hey I
want to do this you know fake bit uh
doing like a dramatic version of your
life and what do you think and I was
like that's genius and by the way let's
collaborate on those I want to work on
this with you and that started the whole
thing
wow that's so weird when somebody comes
to you with an idea that is so you was
that what was that well that's why he
did it because he felt like it was such
a thing that I would do by myself anyway
he just wanted to make sure that he that
he wasn't stepping on my toes it was
very you know uh very nice that way and
and uh yeah and I just thought that
immediately like this is a great idea
and we need to do this and then you went
out to who who approached Daniel
Radcliffe how did you well this is this
is like nine years ten years later
because it was just a viral video for
the first decade and then um uh then
Eric and I thought well it would be
amazing if Daniel Radcliffe wanted to do
this you had him in mind yeah we had
like a short list of actors that we
thought would be good but we've had oh
Daniel's our first choice we could have
Daniel uh and we run a zoom call with
with Daniel Radcliffe which was kind of
surrealistic and he'd read the script
and you know we weren't expecting him to
to you know even like it necessarily we
he was getting on Zoom with you yeah so
we thought but you know I think we take
we've taken a lot of meetings and mostly
it's like oh yeah this is really funny
we'll let you know but but on the first
Zoom call Daniel was like yeah I'm in
where do I buy an accordion I want to
start practicing right now like what
what really yeah he was like apparently
his girlfriend Aaron was like a big
Weird Al fan and would have killed him
if he'd said no that's fantastic and did
he learn can he play the accordion oh
you know he's not ready for like a
one-man show but uh he he learned well
enough to to fake it uh you know uh he
worked with a friend of his in New York
named Pete and then I gave him some
private lessons once he came to La for
pre-production uh and and for the for
the small handful of people that really
know or care he is in fact playing the
right buttons on the accordion I told
him he didn't have to he didn't you know
we could shoot around and we could make
it look like you're playing the
accordion but it was really a point of
Pride with him he really wanted to make
it look look right that's fantastic that
he put that kind of and when you sit
back and you see something like this I
mean it's just like does it seem like a
dream does it seem like reality it's
amazing it's crazy yeah it's very
surreal I mean
you know because because Things Fall
Apart as you know in Hollywood all the
time and it wasn't until we were done
shooting that I thought okay I think I
might be making a movie because at any
point things can just go south I mean we
we had a very uh small budget and a
tight schedule we had 18 days to shoot
the whole movie that's it that's crazy
it's CR and that and we're in the middle
of covid so like if if one of our stars
got covered we're done I mean there's no
reshoots there's like the movie's over
and and the whole every day I was like
please oh no tragedies today let's get
through this and and we did it it was a
small miracle but we got the movie made
and it's out and now I can kind of go
yeah I guess I've got a movie did you
guys have to do one of those crazy like
bubbles lockdown thing to shoot the
movie if it was in the middle of covet
yeah you know you have your different
zones that you're allowed to be in and
every single morning you you had you
know you had your testing and um and we
we only had one person that showed up
and was positive Aaron Paul who starred
in the original Funny or Die video uh he
was going to do a cameo appearance uh
and he showed up and he tested positives
and he had to go home and he was he was
he was heartbroken and he and he was
sick as a dog for the next 10 days it
wasn't like some mild case he was really
sick so that was our only casualty so we
missed him but that was just for a cameo
it was for Cameo yeah so that's not bad
yeah so that's great and then the the
rest is like history
um I I gotta I want to continue the
reason I wanted you to come on here is I
want to do something with you okay okay
so that's done I have no idea
oh
[Music]